how to NAS get involved through the
folks over at Wondrich oh god yeah
wonderful
Anthony Salette and Jeffrey Katzenberg's
new investment company yep and so that
they've supported us and amazing where
does means they are an investor investor
is absolutely and they made the
connection and then obviously upfront
ventures anthemic ventures that people
were really really improved to have in
our cap table as well
is he gonna throw is not putting one of
his cars up there he's got some nice
cars we're gonna work on that yeah I
mean we want to pick our favors you know
very selectively when will people be
able to trade shares between each other
already happening
so really yes we've trade we've traded
that's not a feature in the app it is a
feature in their product eyes dude oh no
we've got it yeah you got it
absolutely so I buy a thousand dollars
worth of the Ferrari yes I can trade it
with somebody else yes you can how do I
do that do I put them up for sale in the
app or somebody requests them so the way
the way we trade is we call it a trading
window is the concept we develop okay
and it's a company yep exactly once
every sixty to ninety days or so we'll
open up trading on each individual asset
we've done it for about half of them so
far during that period of time it's a
limit order book bid and ask where you
could fully see the the bid sort of work
and it almost auctions off so it allows
us to discover a price and then transact
got it so what it happened the last time
did anybody actually trade or is it
really yeah we've seen between the odd
example between five and twenty percent
of the flow changes hand in any given
trading window Wow yeah and that's
because people want a profit take or
some people those different types of
investors some people want to make sure
you know take money off the table and
invest in new deals as they're coming up
so maybe they've allocated a few
thousand to us already yeah and they
feel like okay you know what I'm gonna
keep diversifying that that few thousand
and two more deals so what we usually
see is they reinvest or they hold the
balance for a future deal that they're
excited about what is the largest gain
that's been recorded in a secondary
share over what period at 22 percent
over about six months got it so somebody
bought a car yes you know which one or
then the 1990 Ford Mustang 7up edition
is up 22% Wow our 1977 Lotus Esprit s1
is about up 15% most of the cars
of those cars becoming popular in that
period or you bought low combination
some we bought well and they've sort of
found their way to market value in other
cases comps have happened over the
course of that time so with our 1977
Lotus Esprit for example we put it on
the market at seventy seven thousand
seven hundred dollars right it was a
double O seven car so we thought it'd be
fun to like yeah and then after that
similar cars have gone for over 100 K in
the public auction market so that shows
up in the app people see that as a new
sort of comp point and they've traded it
up over the course of three trading
windows in that direction